hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play forest now
this is just a simple game but it's made
on the Unity engine and I think it might
be what done what well I have choices
and I got season here ok I have two
choices there's two possible levels so
this is gonna be called level one unless
it's really short and then it might be
called just the forest okay
so I was camping out with a friend and
the friends gone dead well too bad
he will be missed I'm not going into
that forest to save him yes I am I
supposed okay here we go
yeah the person who suggested this to me
sorry I don't remember your name I'm
really really bad with names but they
said it was kind of like slender and I
think they meant it was kind of like
sunder given that it was in the woods
I'm pretty sure that might be the only
things that its relation and I think you
collect things I'm not sure my voice is
still a little raggedy from trying to
live stream every single day this
weekend for hours and as much as I as
much as I enjoy doing it I do pay for it
after a while so um I may need to take a
break just a little one country is
unusual others another line they're not
that special
but I do hope that you guys enjoyed the
live streams I do enjoy doing them with
my buddies
oh god my balloons are really going no
fun I'm always wary about running
mechanics because I always believe that
I may not be able to run for extended
periods again I've always really getting
gravelly now I don't know if I'm
supposed to be finding a friend or
getting out of here there's two paths
it's three paths what's that some on
that rock looks like a Blair Witch thing
Oh yep yep yep yep yep yep yep ah the
game crashed that's good news
I'm glad that happened oh no it didn't
it just alt-tab
ah come on baby get back in the game
daddy needs a new pair shoes no no he's
just gonna I just gotta I just gotta
yeah okay it's it's not cooperating all
right I'll be back in just a second okay
we're back all right
sorry about that hopefully this will not
crash it again
ha ha ha ha ha bad idea
God check it off the list I'm full of
that ideas what makes you think this is
my first one first one of the night yeah
hopefully okay so now I officially have
a bad
oh that's why it's a bad idea oh oh well
how was I supposed to know screw you
screw you
it was scary and then it was funny
because it was really attached
girlfriend in the senator yeah so and
everyone knows that's the scariest thing
he could've possibly imagined all right
so I got a sprint back to where I was
and don't pick up that thing I was not
ready for that I thought he's just been
like oh oh it's a bad idea to start with
that one or something like that didn't
know that it was gonna kill me it did
look like a Blair Witch effigy but that
girl looked like the girl from the ring
so I'm not sure kind of ending was
similar to slender so I might this might
be more inspired by slender than I
thought see it shining on the rock over
there I'm not getting it I'm going the
other way any more bad ideas out here
I want to spring up out of that darkness
hmm think so I'm not a good oh wait I
think I saw I saw it like a flash of
light I'm unsure if that was actually
something or a red herring flashes must
just be tearing the game
AHA no I did no I didn't I didn't let me
go up this way I just see things out of
the corner of my eyes
let's just be graphical errors on my end
I'm not even sure if you guys can do
that what the hell level seems to be
pretty big I mean this game obviously
the link is in the description below
like all the games indie horror games I
play and obviously don't judge it on
bugs and stuff like that
shut it on its content because obviously
almost all these games are in beta or
alpha or probably some of them aren't
even ever gonna be released hello door
look look look look look look look
no it's locked well why wouldn't you be
sucked
probably the witch's pun where she goes
to I don't know
cook delicious cookies for the kids did
I go in a circle I'm not back to the
tents
oh no I'm different I'll go for a swim
come on an island or something I don't
even get here can I get off the island
now can I escape I need oil and diesel
guru I don't know I don't your liar I
could bet it's a boat I could paddle use
my hands as scoops Wow hi that's her
that's her she's just standing on the
water
uh hello baby yeah what what what would
sorry going through puberty my voice is
gonna crack a bit um alright so
apparently lady does not want me to
escape
big surprise there don't touch our jet
don't get off our Island and have happy
fun times somewhere else
Oh David I keep seeing these shiny
things that I think I'm supposed to pick
up something double check this looks
like it might be a bit more in-depth
than I thought this isn't just the same
sort of one-shot deal this is actually
kind of involved you guys you play this
it's very well made I mean it's
obviously on the unity engine so it
gives you a lot of tools for creative
freedom like I said I got a create I got
check out some of these um some of these
engines because I I do I do want to take
a crack at being a little bit creative
in terms of what I'm doing hey what's
this you know I wouldn't mind trying to
make a little game if it's oh hey hey
diesel diesel diesel diesel did illegal
I need oil now right ah
oh you stay over there you go take a
bath again she's gone ha but why putter
bah bah bah bah no go away
sure God okay that's a bit like that's
uh okay weird uh ha I need to go this
way
sorry I'm just gonna scooch buy you off
God that is good mechanics getting her
to pop out inside of your vision
by good I mean not good at all so you
can't see anything
Hey yep yep don't need to look back
anymore she's there she is right there
don't know who that lady is but she's
freaky you know you know actually I just
I just realized it's most horror games
and most for anything make the main
character the evil one they make the
character a woman or a little girl or
something like that it's hardly ever a
guy and I just realized the Slender Man
is like the first one where that
actually happens in a significant way
okay this Keys gonna unlock the cabin on
the top of the hill go over here lady
lady get out of the way lady yeah Oh fo
you and your hair and your stupid dress
you remind me the lady from crap here
you know ah she's had an influence ah
that's my me impression from like oh my
god I've said a little kid back there
I've gone hard from the hardened I've
become hardened by all the horror games
these perverts perverted people at their
own who a page can't run ah useless
paper ah I thought the game froze her a
second there but it did not okay so this
game likes to poke fun at its own ha ha
ha ha
I think it's poking fun it's slender
actually
all right
okay that's some okay this is done but
I'm just gonna end it here because I
don't have time to get start back into
and get any significant progress so on
this has been a little taste of the
forest mmm I'm gonna play it again I am
gonna play it again I'm gonna play the
other level to give you taste to that I
don't think I'm gonna beat them because
I want you guys to be able to play them
I like to I kind of like to plug these
little games on links in the description
below give it a try it's pretty fun like
if the mechanics are very similar I like
that it kind of pokes fun enough at the
same time being really really creepy
like obviously that I think that I think
that lady is just uh a remodeled and
very edited version of slender so a lot
obviously this does take a lot of
inspiration from slender the person
recommended this was correct but still
that doesn't mean it's not a good game
it is very good I'm gonna do another
playthrough of the other level to see
what that can bring so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotations
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye